from your standpoint what's what's been
new new stories you've seen recently on
Epstein that's been creating momentum
since the last time we were together
well I guess the most recent one of
course is going to be these Revelations
that have come from the Wall Street
Journal most recently
um about his private calendar
um emails you know a bunch of different
things per the Wall Street Journal they
claim to have thousands of pages of
documents but I'm a little curious you
know where maybe they got these
documents from why now and if they plan
on publicly releasing any of that
because of course you know the reporting
comes from the Wall Street Journal and
they refer to these documents but none
of those have been released to the
public and I'm personally a big fan of
of public transparency but we're kind of
in a post Wikileaks world you know so
tend not to get much of that Source
reporting anymore but I would definitely
like to see it considering a lot of the
names that have come out in connection
with that it's great seeing Wall Street
Journal doing this though right because
they can't say it's a website or it's a
blogger or it's somebody with this when
Walston does it you have to give it to
you have to pay attention to it yeah but
at the same time you know and a lot of
the reporting the way it is is you know
this is what's in the documents and then
we talk to the person referenced and of
course the person distances themselves
from Epstein and says oh well I only
went to them because he was wealthy or I
didn't know anything about this or that
and it's hard to know if that's really
true to be honest because some people
have claimed that and then evidence has
come out showing it was a bit different
and then they're like oh well
and and nothing really happens you know
you referenced a a post Wikileaks world
right now obviously a reference to
Julian Assange break that down what does
that mean since that transpired what
over a decade ago I want to say what
where do you see the the current state
of affairs today so I sort of you know
uh looking at like Assange and Wikileaks
you know what they were doing obviously
before
um Assange was incarcerated uh was
taking Source documents that they
received and putting them out for the
public uh to look at and View and draw
their own conclusions and it you know
how investigative reporting has changed
since then is I think pretty clear I
mean you compare a lot of the how
Wikileaks handled you know their access
to Source documents versus something
like the Twitter files for example I
mean there's a pretty big
shift between then and now and
personally I prefer the the former model
because more information more
transparency I think that ultimately is
a and serves the public interest more
how does that affect reporters like you
today whistleblowers stuff like that how
what the mindset of you guys doing this
intense investigative journalism how's
how things change well you know I
intentionally like what I do I don't try
and work with people that are in a
position to like have face jail time for
giving me information because given what
like I know and what's pretty obvious
about the surveillance state today I
don't feel like I can guarantee anyone's
security
let me ask how many people have actually
reached out to you who are insiders
saying hey can we talk offline because I
have some information that I want to
share with you I mean a couple but again
you know I don't live in the U.S so it's
hard for me just online to know that
they're for real and I don't want to
again put anyone in a position of danger
so I tend to go with things that are
public record open source but people
that do want to work with those types of
sources everything that's happened with
Julian Assange and Wikileaks and even
you know with um with what happened with
Snowden and then a lot of the people
that for example leech documents or
shared documents with the intercept for
example three of those guys went to
prison and that was after Snowden and
Assange so I think there's definitely
been an intentional chilling effect on
on that sharing of of transparency and I
think obviously that's in great
detriment what about your personal like
do you ever worry about them I mean
because it's completely positive they
could get to somebody in jail and say
that he committed suicide how he like
you you fear for your own safety at all
well I mean people ask me that a lot but
frankly you know the state of the world
today
um I feel like it's incumbent on all of
us to stand up and say something and
again I'm not trying to work with like
classified information and stuff you
know I think if I was it would be a
different situation for sure
um but I think also at the same time
like if you live your life in fear
that's going to impede you from doing
stuff that's important
um and you know I'm really grateful for
the platform I have today
um and you know I have a I guess an
ability to put information together that
helps you know people see some of these
um you know power structures that aren't
necessarily visible to everyone
um and I feel like it's you know my duty
and responsibility to do that because
frankly you know the more people we
really need to raise awareness I think
about about these you know power
structures these situations and and how
we got here because you know especially
if you're a parent of
kids like I am I mean you know you just
let things keep going this way it's not
going to be good for anybody so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]